pete is has got to be literally the best
human being i've ever met kim kardashian
is totally smitten with her boyfriend
pete davidson
and now etie is learning how pete's
improved kim's quality of life it really
is a game changer
a source tells e.t pete and kim are so
in love as for the reality star's
demeanor these days we're told kim's
living a full life quote kim is light
and happy with pete and it shows in so
many ways including being a mom with her
work in her friendships and more
it's
amazingly full
meanwhile pete has made a real effort to
immerse himself into kim's world
including bonding with her four kids
north saint chicago and somme
our source adds he is so amazing with
her children and she loves seeing him be
silly with them and take an interest in
their lives
and kim's whole family definitely agrees
i love the chemistry that kim and him
have together it's really sweet i
thought you said the chemistry he was
like okay chemistry
chemistry it's a deep connection that's
only grown stronger since keep made
things official back in october
according to e.t source pete is fully
committed to kim and loves being with
her no matter what they're doing
he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
and it seems like the snl alum is on the
same page when it comes to putting
family first yep
pete recently sat down with kevin hart
for his upcoming peacock show and
revealed his biggest goal becoming a dad
my favorite thing ever which i've yet to
achieve is i want to have a kid
that's like my dream and get this pete
is already in full prep mode it would be
so fun to dress up a little dude like
you know like you saw it's just like i'm
so excited for like that chapter so like
that's kind of what i'm just preparing
for now is trying to be like as good as
a dude and develop and get better so
when that happens it's just easier our
source says kim and pete are moving at
their own pace
quote they are living in the moment but
also see a future together life is good
i have a new boyfriend i'm just having a
really good time well we hope the good
times keep rolling as pete is set to
officially appear in season two of the
kardashians giving fans an inside look
at the pair's romance sexy time and all
fave yeah do you want to shower with me
really quick
[Music]
you